Speaker 1: Let's go to Alexander, the Texan.
Next, Alexander the Texan. You're on the air.
Hi, David, can you hear me? I can hear you.
Speaker 2: Fine, OK? I was just wondering,
so there seems to be a subset of leftist in
America that I would call America bad leftist.
OK. What do you think? What do you think
drives there? I would call it propagandistic
coverage of like this Russia Ukraine situation.
Speaker 1: I think you'd really have to ask them.
I mean, I think if your starting point is the U.S.
is uniquely bad, then that's your hammer, right?
And so everything will look like a nail. Russia
Ukraine is an opportunity to say the U.S. is bad.
Venezuela is an opportunity to say the U.S. is
bad. Cuba is in opposition. You know, if if you're
committed to the hammer, everything looks like
a nail. And I think I think it's that for some
specific people, we've later found out about
financial ties to some authoritarian regimes.
And so for some people, there may be a financial
aspect to it, but I don't think there's anything
particularly hidden. You know, I mean, I think
it's just a lot for a lot of people. It's like,
Hey, look at this terrible thing China's doing.
Yeah, but the U.S. also does bad things, right?
Yeah. And I criticize those. But we're talking
about China right now. I think you get the point,
right? And so I think I think it's quite
it's quite that simple. That's all it is.
Speaker 2: OK. Yeah. Well, that's that's
really all that I wanted. I'll let you move
on to the next caller. I value your opinion,
David, and thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. And are you're
are you bunkering hunkering down for
the upcoming winter storm there in Texas?
Speaker 2: Oh yes, I am. And I'm hoping that
we have a little bit better luck this year
and a little more competence on the part
of my particular business fatality. That's
what I'm hoping. And this aid as a whole,
Speaker 1: that's what I'm hoping
for. All right. Stay safe down there,
Alexandra. Thank you. Thank you very much, David.
All right. Alexander, the Texan checking in.